as we come up on year three of the
pandemic the nation is solely pulling
out of the nosedive that disrupted life
as we know it but recovery may still be
a long way off for many restaurants if
at all chris van cleave reports
breit martin was intended to be a denver
mainstay bringing neighbors together
over fried chicken and froze
instead owner jared rick's dream has
been dashed by covid i feel like we're
kind of the canary in the coal mine like
nearly 6 out of 10 restaurants
nationwide riggs saw his business
plummet by more than half as omicron
surged forcing him to shut down probably
harder in 2021 than it was in 2020 for
us omicron and inflation were a double
whammy double whammy and then i think
staffing was a big one that's always
been one
you know i've actually been like the
dishwasher here for the last four months
riggs was approved for aid from the
restaurant revitalization fund a 28.6
billion dollar federal program to help
struggling restaurants but it ran out of
money after just a third of applicants
got help
chook charcoal chicken also missed out
on covet relief now omicron and snapping
shortages are clipping their wings
it's hard to navigate chief operating
officer elizabeth nicholas says rising
costs are also a challenge chicken
jumped eight percent in a week it's
totally brace for impact and it's been
difficult
for sure there's been days that are way
harder than others thank you so much
it's gotten so tough one in four
colorado restaurants now say they are
thinking about shutting down in the next
six months and of course this isn't just
a story here in denver it's an issue
facing restaurants across the country
nationally 91 percent of restaurants
report difficulty hiring 89 percent have
raised prices and as many as 8 in 10 say
they are in danger of closing without
assistance we are on the verge of an
extinction event for this industry an
extinction event
it's that dire we need to renew and
reauthorize that relief fund for our
restaurants i think that's critically
important denver mayor michael hancock
was one of 28 mayors to send a letter to
congress asking for more aid the reality
is it's a very difficult
situation and so when one restaurant
closes we feel a little bit of our our
spirit has died and that's a that's a
real challenge for us
but further covet relief remains a
non-starter in washington do you get the
sense that congress is hearing you're
pleased no i think i think we kind of
got forgotten feeling forgotten and now
starting over for cbs saturday morning
i'm chris van cleave in denver
shot a dish segment this week and it's
clear the struggle for restaurants is is
far from over yeah i know a lot of
restaurants lowered their prices during
the pandemic so it might seem as they
raise their prices to catch up
they probably have to do double digits
yeah increases it really potentially
threatens the landscape of our cities
all across this country big and small
certainly does